guys are gonna talk about frozen to
today are you guys excited are you
excited to talk about frozen John I've
been waiting for this for a long time my
god once frozen one came out we just
lost sight of frozen we haven't heard
about it since I haven't heard anything
about it and this movie just comes out
of nowhere
unexpected there's been nothing on the
radio in television in stores before
Coco to remind me that frozen is coming
all cynical thoughts aside of
anticipation going into this like I was
looking forward to it but I I did have a
little bit of that feeling of I'm kind
of over frozen I gotta admit I quite
enjoyed this movie I had a really good
time sitting back relaxing enjoying this
flick man let's just kick off the IMDB
log line because we don't want to try to
express it John's read it onna Elsa
Kristoff Olaf and Sven leave arendelle
to travel to an ancient autumn bound
forest of an enchanted land they set out
to find the origin of Elsa's powers in
order to save their kingdom well the
first one I thought was a movie that had
a big world but it was a rather
self-contained movie when you really
think about it starts off like a simple
Disney movie you think it's gonna be a
kind of cliche one but they end up
server ting a lot of tropes which i
think is what really helped leave its
mark I think that's a big part we'll
make that movie special this one
definitely goes a lot bigger a lot more
mystical but it does this thing that
reminds me of Ralph breaks the internet
now that I think about it how that movie
halfway through starts to go a lot more
like dark tangos more somber a little
more melodramatic
add a little bit more dramatic heft and
weight to the film it really succeeds in
that department I think there are gonna
be people who are kind of split on the
storytelling for this movie there are
things about the storytelling that I
thought were great
there are handling of some characters
first off especially that I wasn't a big
fan of but I want to start off with this
number one thing that I have gotten so
annoyed by was probably my favorite
thing in this movie laughs yeah hi Olaf
was hysterical easily had the funniest
scene in this movie I will not explain
what it was it genuinely earned a round
of applause it was a great great moment
and only Josh GAD as Olaf could have
pull that off
I think if you've seen the movie you'll
know what I'm talking about he's gotta
say that you're like I know it scene
you're talking about man but John what
do you think of the animation also the
animation was gorgeous I mean they've
really really come a long way over the
years with things like texture of hair
skin water physics fire and this movie
has a plot point that dives directly
toward the elements earth water air and
fire they demonstrate just how far that
animation has come so it really is
beautiful to behold and also in the
lighting and in the 3d because the 3d is
really evident the entire film what we
saw this in RealD 3d shouts out to Ryan
Garcia for inviting us man in all
sincerity the 3d was gorgeous that's
animated movie I think we saw in 3d was
lego movie - and that was great this
exceeds it I think it's because we saw
it I call it the the Christopher
Lambert's but I know that's not the
correct terminology was it called they
projected this in 14 foot Lambert's
which to my understand I'm in foot
Lambert's are a measurement of luminance
which is light how much light you're
hitting the screen with most good
average screenings have around 4 to 6
this was 14 so you have a ton more light
and a ton more fine control over how
much light is hitting the screen and for
3d especially that is essential and a
lot of times when you're seeing bad 3d
or seeing something projected with a low
level of luminance so it was bright yeah
that's basically it in a very
oversimplified explain that at the
theater we're all like oh I didn't feel
it was like a char like it's not it's
not just about cranking up the
brightness because cranking up the
brightness just watching the colors out
it's it's it's a little more complicated
but yeah basically I made for some of
the best 3d projection you could think
of yeah and not every theaters doing in
that format but if you can like a
Cinemark I would especially watch it in
that format because it truly is
beautiful especially in a lot of these
sequences that kind of remind me of
Fantasia where the backgrounds all black
but then elsa is doing some of her cool
making stuff out of ice thing that she
does and those figures really popped a
lot it was gorgeous absolutely gorgeous
so some of my favorite things in this
movie this is more else's movie but I
rewatched the frozen one I noticed that
it was really Anna who's the main
character and like while all
the focus is pretty much on Elsa she
really is more of the supporting
character in that movie Anna takes us on
the adventure I go find Elsa yeah and
she just gets more screen time and then
here it's really Elsa who's the lead in
this film and I think that's the the
smart choice for doing this one while it
does explore the origins of where her
powers come from and whatnot I don't
know if I'd say this movie is more
personal than the first one the first
one relies heavily so much on the
dynamics between sisterhood in that film
something I really identify with in this
movie Anna and Elsa are separate a lot
of the time and as a matter of fact in
the first half of this movie I started
feeling like they're looking for things
for Anna to do like whenever Anna and
Elsa are on-screen together I really
liked it but then there were also times
where it seemed like they didn't really
know what to do with their other
characters they had this really funny
bit going on with Olaf about maturity
Anna like I said is great her last half
I really liked her there Kristoff though
is my biggest complaint like that's the
one that's the most obvious of we need
something to do with Kristoff but like
that is a true sequel lightest issue
that I think this movie had because this
is one thing they do at Kristoff it's
not even a spoiler because it's all they
do with him in the movie he has a sitcom
joke in the whole thing he wants to
propose it's to Anna
but then she keeps misunderstanding him
some things keep getting in the way they
interrupt him and he can't just seem to
ask her will you marry me they don't do
anything unique with it there's no
character enhancement it leads to this
song that Christophe has which was I
thought did you like that song I thought
it was a funny song I thought the the
visuals it did for it were really funny
I won't give away specifically what they
were going for I thought it was really
amusing I was thinking okay are we
sitting through this reoccurring OneNote
bit with Kristoff just so we could get
this song is this gonna be worth it kind
of like this song is good the song is
funny it's not the strongest song in the
film but it doesn't really make up for
the lack of writing for Kristoff who I
thought was a really rich character in
the first one yeah and especially
because during that moment of the film
he's got another character with him and
I almost expected they were gonna take
his character someplace different in
light of the conflict he's experiencing
and then they just kind of don't they'd
like side lighten him have one portion
this movie he just gets sidelined and it
doesn't even like our main characters I
don't think the main cares once bring
him up this conundrum yeah where it's
like the mission is at hand and so
everybody from the first movie who's our
core group it's like we're going with
you and that makes all the sense but
yeah it's like once they're on the
mission it doesn't seem like the mission
necessitates them the main thrust of the
drama is Elsa's gonna do this alone or
is Elsa gonna do this with Anna and the
rest of the crews help while this movie
is bigger and while they're exploring
this this thing with like Elsa's origins
and while there have these sequences
technically intense yet I'd never felt
the stakes of the situation I'm not sure
how to put it because this movie gets a
lot more sombre more heavy a little bit
more melancholy it's going for deeper
things for some reason I wasn't really
gripped into the emotional stakes
there's one scene in the movie actually
it's it's the first thing they tease
with the trailers where else is running
into the ocean and that scene actually
like they do a lot of that scene that
you don't see in the trailer and I
actually thought that scene was pretty
scary kind of like old-school Disney
where this is a little this is pretty
unsettling and it does go a lot darker
and I think a lot of it comes down to
the fact there's not really a villain in
the movie thing I had trouble with
overall in this is that you have a lot
of interesting circumstances and I don't
even mind that there is no villain I
feel like it's fair to have obstacles
and circumstances be your villains and
the sins of the past be your villains
the problem is I thought they had a lot
of great ideas and they just didn't
really make the plot itself urgent
around them so by the time the way the
actual events got executed felt kind of
perfunctory to the point where when the
actual resolve was happening I was like
oh oh the movies end it feels like an
interesting idea and interesting journey
for Elsa to go on especially but it
doesn't ultimately feel of great
consequence even though there is like
big dramatic stuff happening so I don't
know I mean this is a movie that worked
but for me in broad strokes and in
scenes more than a truly satisfying
animated film experience and especially
coming off the first one there is almost
no subversion aspect to this one other
than having an atypical there's no real
villain at the same time you know maybe
males in their late 20s are not the
target audience yeah like if you want my
opinion I felt like all the
themes and a lot of the choices a lot of
the ideas had teeth and just the plot
mechanics didn't have teeth yeah I think
this is a good family movie and I think
the musical numbers which is I'm
surprised waited this long to talk about
I think the musical numbers in the movie
are really good I would say heard none
of them are as catchy as the first one
the first name the movie the first one
seemed like they were designed to be
karaoke songs II know like they were
good in the context of the story but
they also do feel like so long as you
would hear on the radio I gotta be
honest like most of the songs kind of
bleed together for me in this movie yeah
I definitely walk out with a particular
melody I remember door that was stuck in
my ear but it all like while it's on and
and you know you're listening to the
lyrics go by like yeah Chris Pitts it
fits the movie I don't I wouldn't say
it's bad or anything like that no no no
I don't even think it comes down to
expectation honestly because I think
what a lot of people are gonna be saying
is there's no let it go in here you know
there's no there's no song that's gonna
be that and I'm like wow I don't think
it's fair to put that weight on this
movie I'd still say that this is yeah
it's pretty cool movie and then you know
they have like other characters in here
like the only new character that made up
a standout presence to me would be
sterling K Browns character the black
guy in them trailers who actually gets
to talk like it's where arendelle has a
lot of different ethnic citizens and yet
none of them are practically character
no he had a standout presence in there
I'm hearing a lot of people who really
are upset about this movie and then I'm
seeing a lot of people who love this
movie when we walked out of the theater
everyone I'm familiar with that was at
the screening was in love with this
movie and I was more like yeah yeah and
I mean I don't know not in love with the
first frozen but I do have to give that
movie respect you can argue that it's
overrated or whatever but for the amount
of adulation it's received I think some
of that is warranted this movie feels
just kind of like yeah it's an all right
follow-up I liked it but it doesn't feel
as groundbreaking or as significant as
the first one no it doesn't but I would
also still say that's worth watching the
feeders certainly the visual experience
and I think there's actually a pretty
good amount of a strong laughs to be had
I laugh quite a bit if I were to sum it
up I would give this a 4 out of 5 maybe
like a three and a half
for how come whenever I go low you go
higher and then whenever I go high you
go lower you know it's the game of
opposites why don't we have the exact
same two going for point two pitchfork
duck even when I'm like I'll go three
point five you go I probably give it
like a 3.75 what the hell John I don't
know guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell do
you think there should be a frozen three
where they discover they have a brother
they didn't know about who picks his
nose eats his boogers
that's a callback to life
and the first person move you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell yeah I like to end
this with a page from the day shout-out
to a woman named Rosa Parra you might
have heard as mentioned many times that
she has been doing her own solo reviews
it's not a podcast Rosa's reviews check
out her blog Instagram and Twitter she
is killing it Rosa has been stepping out
of her shell she is the antithesis to
conceal don't feel she is revealing does
that work she is feeling not concealing
completely revealing and stealing our
views you need to stop Rosa gonna shut
you down because we need our subscribers
and you are taking them all the way from
us see right claim all your videos for
ourselves you might be the Lady Stark of
our channel where the Prince Hans of
your channel cuz we're gonna backstab
you eventually and then you know and I
get it I still have to defeat me us
frozen Reve this is the best shout out